[Music]
so tell me have you done this a lot met
people on the computer service
don't you fine it's always the same you
mean them special followed by them that
down but I tell myself brace up this
time it will be different
which is why I'm a soccer fest Europe a
deception my god my name is in fact not
Brian it's Roy
[Music]
to the future how much the lynches worth
nearly three million pounds there's a
lot you bloody bet I'm gonna take it off
is that your grandson it's too soon to
be getting so close to him
I've grown very fond of you do you know
who you are
you're the only person on this planet
who makes me feel that I'm not alone
I know things about you who you really
are you don't want to do this Roy
[Music]
the adrenaline rush
[Music]
what if it is seems like you've had
quite a past enough to last several
lifetimes
and just a blink your last chest forever
you know it's very peculiar doing things
you'd never imagined secrets between you
God the devil
and the dead you know him
you
[Music]
you